alito está want to con agua en yucatán
my la amazonía árboles con color verde
intenso con ríos super grandes y
correntosos con muchas historias para
contar ya y provengo yo de la provincia
de napo
diversidad con frutas como pueden ver la
chunta el la agrón celia el un
dura agua pero hoy hoy les quiero contar
sobre una fruta específica la paragua
físicamente nada agradable como pueden
observar nada apetecible como la ven ni
siquiera pensarían en probar porque yo
también lo pensé al principio pero saben
que es lo interesante de esto el proceso
para poder deleitar de esta fruta
alguien se dio el tiempo de querer saber
si es que el primero se podía comer esta
fruta efectivamente se podía comer así
que se acercó al árbol y tuvo que
esperar a que caiga no podemos cortarla
del árbol no podemos forzarla porque si
no no estará lista para poder deleitar
después de esto la cocina de unos diez a
quince minutos con un poquito de sal al
que al culminar abrió esta fruta y se
dio cuenta que había una exótica
con un sabor único diferente que ninguna
otra fruta tenía solamente eso
pero eso no es lo más interesante sino
su significado
fruto de la esperanza de donde yo vengo
ese es el significado así como hubo una
persona quien se dio el tiempo de
descubrir esta fruta alguien también se
dio el tiempo de descubrirme de darme un
espacio ingresé a un curso de
comunicación no les voy a mentir al
principio estaba súper nervioso con
miedo insegura y no quería fracasar
muchos de nosotros dejamos de hacer las
cosas que queremos por miedo al fracaso
porque nos han enseñado que el fracaso
es mal pero no nos han enseñado que
también es el camino hacia el éxito
por cuestiones de la vida pasé a
estudiar a un colegio nocturno público
donde tuve la oportunidad de compartir
con compañeros y compañeras que ya eran
padres madres de familia algunos eran
abandonados eran huérfanos sus padres
vivían en las zonas super lejanas de la
ciudad
pero
eso no era nada para lo que ellos
querían
superarse iban todas las noches de lunes
a viernes a estudiar a prepararse a
cumplir una meta más que tal vez no
pudieron culminar años atrás
a tener
saber más sobre los conocimientos
también he tenido la oportunidad de ver
compañeras que van inclusive con sus
hijos y es difícil créanme es difícil
ver cómo ellas no pueden concentrarse en
sus estudios tal vez en algún momento
fracasaron sí pero quieren y tienen esas
ganas de querer superarse
pero la realidad es que en este entorno
donde yo me encuentro las oportunidades
se desvanecen las personas que deben
darlas son pocas
estoy en un entorno donde no nos ofrece
muchas oportunidades donde son muy pocas
donde las personas
no ven mucho en nosotros
piensan que no tenemos las mismas
capacidades
pero si las tenemos y hoy estoy aquí
para demostrando que sí podemos que yo
soy de ese grupo del que también quiere
superarse
tomando en cuenta la frase de albert
eisntein nunca considera es el estudio
como una obligación sino como una
oportunidad para penetrar en el bello y
maravilloso mundo del saber
ustedes educadores que tienen la
oportunidad y el privilegio de compartir
con los jóvenes ayuden a cambiar ese
concepto negativo que a veces tenemos
los jóvenes porque yo también lo tenía
al principio
pensaba queda en los trabajos la
monografía los proyectos los profesores
mi papá me pega si no me ve al colegio
mi mamá me regaña si saco malas notas a
veces lo sentían como una obligación
ayuden a cambiar ese concepto a uno
positivo a uno de querer autoeducarse de
querer aprender de querer saber de
querer enriquecerse en todos los
conocimientos posibles ustedes tienen
esa oportunidad
ahora les pregunto quieren causar
bienestar
les voy a compartir estos pasos estos
tres pasos para que ustedes puedan
causar bienestar el primero muestra
interés diles que si pueden que ellos
son capaces que lo vas a lograr que no
importa si fracasa solo es de hacerlo y
arriesgarse
la segunda brinda oportunidad crea
espacios actividades donde los jóvenes
puedan desarrollarse y puedan descubrir
sus aptitudes en lo que son buenos
también motivan
motivarles sin importar que están
fallando porque a veces fallamos y nos
falta de alguien que nos diga mi hija
está bien dale tu puedes entonces nos
falta esa persona que nos aliente que
nos dé la mano que nos ayude
porque a veces no hay esas personas
y la tercera es un seguimiento vuelves a
motivar animales
apoya les da le brinda esa mano
qué tal vez otras personas no lo hacen
si a mí no me hubiesen brindado el
espacio tanto en este curso no hubiese
descubrir una aptitud más
de ámbito de comunicación ya que yo
tenía créanme compañeras y compañeros
que se destacaban en todo entonces eran
buenos en el deporte en las artes en la
música pero yo no era buena en nada así
que yo me preguntaba una y otra vez en
que soy bueno para que soy bueno esto me
lo repetía un montón de veces hasta como
les comenté ingresé este curso y tuve la
oportunidad de descubrir una de mis
aptitudes
no lo hubiese logrado si alguien no me
hubiese brindado este espacio y esta
oportunidad tal vez no hubiese
descubierto mis aptitudes mi talento
contándoles la verdad me sentí a superar
en ese curso porque no me encontraba no
me encontraba así como esta fruta que
nadie quería descubrir nadie pero hubo
esa persona quien sí se atrevió a ser
así como esa persona a quien sí se
atreve se atrevió a apostar por mí a
decir bueno en ti hay algo y toca
florecer
porque ni yo misma sabía en lo que yo sé
lo que tenía por esta gracia de esta
persona
me ayuda a descubrir y hoy -por otra
oportunidad que me han brindado y estoy
muy agradecida de estar aquí parada
frente a ustedes porque esta es una
experiencia más para mí es una
experiencia muy bonita he estado
esperando este momento si me he
equivocado discúlpenme está un poquito
nerviosa pero bueno el último y tercer
es un seguimiento
no lo olvides porque hay personas que si
no se han mostrado interés nos han dado
la oportunidad y el espacio pero después
de estos dos pasos nos olvidan y no nos
vuelven o nos preguntan cómo te va te
sientes bien en lo que en tu ámbito el
que está en la comunicación sabes que mi
hija hay un evento pensé en ti te doy
esa oportunidad
repite hace una retroalimentación de
estos pasos una y otra vez las veces que
sean necesarias con unas dos o tres
personas con grupo grande con un grupo
pequeño
no importa la cuestión es hacerlo
después de haberles comentado un poquito
de mi experiencia de mi vida muy
chiquitita les invito a todos ustedes a
descubrir su paraguas gracias
[Aplausos]